join me a whopping Mark Johnson
okay thanks Kurt and welcome everyone
okay well yeah so I guess I just found
out that part of the tradition of this
gathering to say a little bit about how
I got here which is sensible and as I
look back on it how did I get here have
a lot to do with stuff like you're doing
right now and so like water today we'll
be doing some fun stuff that I hope if
this is a video camera that's just
watching what's going on this black box
we'll come back to that about a half an
hour talk about what that really is no
just so you know it's not a great
mystery you're looking at cosmic rays
meaning through the building and running
right through that box so that had
something to do with electrical charges
in water so so it gets kind of soothing
thing to look to gaze upon as we go
through this i think but there are
viciously high-energy parks that are
doing and they're very tiny and so when
we have another experiment going on over
here that we'll talk about in a second
so these equations are not unfortunately
for you to play with and so I don't
wouldn't let you know courage people to
come up and do a hands-on apparatus that
we have going on but you're welcome to
come up and take a look at hug that's
nothing but a cold spot how did I get
here well you know i groped oakland
california right and class of 73 and
that's a public you know high school at
the darn good public high school and I
got here because of a really
inspirational chemistry teacher named
James fan he was so good at teaching
chemistry they made a principal and so
you stop teaching chemistry after club
doesn't work daily but I got interested
in doing chemistry and science because
well of course I was you know I can see
this you know condos of politics
science we just had a big oil spill in
the bear in from a tanker crashed into
one of the bridges and so I have science
project on what oil does two things like
the San Francisco Bay so on but I went
on from that this place is a i divert
the hill right above the hilly place and
so you look up when you grow up and I
grow up in a flat lands and in that
innovator I you look up there this great
strange building up there is called
Elora called science and that's where
they took us when we were your age and
you went around and did little
experiments and appreciated what people
did in the in the National Laboratory
associated with this place and it's this
guy actually that Lawrence Lawrence
Berkeley Laboratory so Lawrence Hall of
Science that's Ernest Lawrence and he's
a New Haven guy I'm making this stuff up
so it turns out he lived here Whitney
Avenue do you drive up you're driving
back up to Hammond you'll go right by
look over on the right and that's Ernest
Lawrence's house I'd be here from New
Haven the Berkeley you ask we'll come
back to that little bit okay so mark did
pretty well for himself with the with
the laboratory that I visited was famous
for this and so many of you know that
there are elements many elements that
make up the primary species we linked
together in chemistry to make molecules
and so on and so they in fact went out
and discovered a bunch of new ones using
an instrument that Lawrence felt when he
was a Yale and so unfortunately because
he built it at Berkeley they got
elements named after them per kelley of
california lawrencium has his own
element as it turned out you know
unfortunately no new haven idiom or
anything fun like that that we could
have had it we had managed to keep a
hold of lower that's how I got into this
business they look like a lot of
exciting things going on in science and
I learned
a bit about how they did these things
you have stuff going on in New Haven
that's just like that there are
fabulously empower phul instruments that
are in play a couple of blocks from
where we're standing that our veterans
at Yale manages and the one that I want
to talk to you about today is called the
Yale proteomics center and they I don't
think they have tours I haven't checked
it out but they should because it's
business of proteomics it's very
powerful stuff for medicine using you
can many of you have heard they can take
a look at the genetics makeup in your
particular body then target remedies for
disease or anticipates you might get
into you by rapidly looking at your
particular cold and then targeting
therapies for the vote proteomics is
what that a is called and we want to
talk about how Yale actually did a lot
to make proteomics happen and that is a
technical thing it's not a biological
thing the highly technical simple
chemical process that sees that started
this whole revolution subtle ran talk
about today is what do you need in order
to do Romans well okay so we're going to
look at up net molecules molecules that
are important in your body are big h2o
is a tiny molecule we need that too but
the molecules that do the work to do all
the biological functions that we enjoy
are you can't if you look at all the
individual atoms you just can't even see
them in there so this is an object
cytochrome C and so we want to think
about the structure of that thing it
weighs twelve thousand times the weight
of a single hydrogen ham and why the
water molecules so we're looking at a
free big object that's the sort of
minimum thing you have to start looking
at in order to look at biological
processes so where are we know we're
done with water right so we're now
moving on
look at how we treat gigantic objects
like this and and and know exactly what
they're composed of two to within one
atom resolution and so this thing will
talk about this taking it contains 100
amino acid residues that's something we
have to get our ever think about what
amino acid residue who have to do with
anything they love these loops these
colors and all that but what's in each
one of these is a bit of a molecule
thing and they're kind of you know
manageable so this is an amino acid it
has an acid it has this is the amine and
we're in your body in a protein they all
link up by spitting out water molecules
and they make these really long change
and that we can understand just like
you're snapping needs together and
making a legs very much like that a
protein is a biz along under Sophie next
and then all different colors and your
particular p that encodes your world is
just if i knew the exact ordering of all
the color I don't know everything I
think there is to know about how about
your particular body works and so how do
we going to get the deep the decoding of
the color sequence okay so that's I know
now this is the very simple thing about
that my my amino acid be right each one
of these is a molecule going together
those peptide linkages and so I just
want to know what you order it and so
suppose that I broke it apart if I took
looking but physically look a necklace
and I just booked at half every which
way you'd be possibly break in half okay
and somebody broke in here for example
as you see these two couple together and
then the next door alright you break it
another place for another place and if I
break it in all the ways you can break
it then mathematically understand the
ordering of all the little pieces you
got you can uniquely recreate what your
particular
that's what they do in the proteomic
sent very precise breaking in and
measuring of all component pieces is the
game of proteomic how do you do that how
would you know okay you have a big
molecule there you break it if you break
the necklace in half and now you need to
know what the two halves are oh I did
that in my house with necklace of life
unlike way two halves and that would
tell me how quick how much was in each
one so I could do way that would be a
good way that I might use in order each
each time it broke ever see one and for
two and three way those each each each
one at a time and then we tell me where
the thing broke and the problem of
course and you want to weigh something
if you want to weigh a physical object
you can you can use gravity in order to
pull on it and then you can figure out
the strength of that force and use that
to get the weight but a molecule has
almost nomads it does gravity is doing
anything to a molecule that's just right
out and so you need to have a big force
that you can put on a molecule that you
can do something with in order to use it
to determine the mass of s of that
object please don't want to weigh it
brownies out and it turns out that
electricity is the ticket the
electricity is going to give you another
force that you can use to move things
around alright and so until it's great
the basic thing to understand if that's
the Largo positive electricity we have
positive and a battery of all seeing the
puffs plus and minus on the battery
right plus is going to attract you put
an electrical charge object in there it
has same charge as one of the
will be repelled from it and attracted
to the other one that's so hard to
understand and so if i have an
electrical charge and i put it in a
between a positive and a negative region
it will just run away from it'll be
accelerated towards the electrode that
has the opposite polarity to the charge
that i put in so electrical forces can
push little molecules around easily it
turns out that that gives me enough
information in order to weigh them very
accurate so the game plan is I wanted so
it like if I really want to do
proteomics on a necklace of amino acids
I'll need to put electrical charges on
in order to use my charging game in
order to measure what the way the
weights are so i'll just put plus plus
plus excellent amino acid ma'am I broke
it apart the two pieces that I got both
have electrical charges and then I could
use the emotion that I can induce in
those of charts things in order to weigh
each one independently as simple as that
except it isn't so simple because these
molecules are not so easy to put a
charge so it happily on each one of the
amino it'll be a very hard thing to do
you could be child's play way these
things up to measure they're competent
so how do we do that so it turns out
fast moving ions oh but I use the thing
that you call a any object that has an
electrical charge has a name I what an
eye on okay I on ionic ionic objects are
the plus thing in here so that that has
now had electrical charge on it and so
if you have a very fast-moving charged
object you need to smash it into us
stainless steel plate well it smashes
into it and
and fragments come out of it that turned
out to be very easy to detect and so I
can detect it very efficiently I use
electricity to weigh them but there's a
catch and that I need very very little
pressure we're living in atmospheric
pressure right now that's a very dense
viscous medium you see professional
tennis player they're your golf
professionals they're using the
viscosity of the air in order to twist
the ball right fly through it they're
using friction the friction through the
errors are useful for sports really bad
the way molecules because you want to
push the book that electric field but
then as they swim through the air
they're losing their push that you gave
them when you started the process off so
you need to get rid of all that air so
you get a very very little pressure
environment in order to waste things out
and that takes longer to be my fourth
typical billion times less than the
Earth's atmosphere is what you need nor
did you get this okay so when you do
that and you get objects that look like
this this is what's called a mass
spectrometer the thing that weighs
things out using electricity and it's a
big kid to me you know cylindrical metal
things like that because you got to get
rid of all the air inside of it so you
got to pump it out in order to get this
thing to work and so we have one of
these and kind of able bunch of these
down in the proteomic century Gale and
so on and they're really good and so
when I was in high school we learned
that there were the weights of the
molecules for example these hallways 28
and calculation that I did when I was in
high school chemistry and because they
have the same numbers of protons and
neutrons but if you weigh them out with
a modern modern mass spectrometer spikes
here is how much something weighs and
this is like 27 28 and so within that
what i thought was only one mass unit
was good enough for me is actually the
precision
which similar molecules are different
and that can be measured it is profound
so to put some numbers out one part of
the millions to measure the absolute
mass of a molecular object is trivial so
that's that's it that's their daily
routine that we do not text center okay
so we need we can measure it we all we
have to do is get these things in the
indeed within an environment without any
gas around it and here's a problem all
the molecules that are worth anything in
my body are absolutely dependent on
being in it that means that they're in a
water environment most your body water
and those big molecules that I was just
talking about a big diff the proteins
the DNA and all that stuff is it gotta
be in the water like a fish out of water
you take the stuff out of there it is an
innovative it is a very unhappy object
right intrinsically needs to be in that
solution environment in order to exist
and so this is bad like if I could just
get it out and get rid of all the water
and put it in an empty vacuum i get i
get the weight absolutely perfectly and
so everyone knowing this for 40 years at
least said well it's you know would be
great if we could just get these
molecules and use a mass spectrometer
may be off to the races people known
that forever and no one can get them out
it's a simple problem engineering
problem but install the whole deal okay
so let's think about this probably the
same biological molecules like in here
only present but you have water so why
don't you just take it out turns out
that the energy that it takes to pull a
protein molecule out of water is much
larger than the energy it takes to break
it in half and so you haven't your stuff
right if i want to reach in there and
grab somebody
have a whole family come out together I
keep ripping you out of the center row
you don't hanker hanging on it's harder
thinking but i keep getting only one of
you out because this strength with which
you're held together is less than
they've done the energy it takes me to
pull and the outside is so you're not
doomed in order to figure out how that's
even a good intrinsic problem you're
never going to be able to beat it well
then stop people to try it so what
people did is they put some protein and
they dry it out you know freeze-dried
kind of thing please pump it up so you
didn't ask to get ripped out in the
water you just evaporate the water away
and others this dead protein molecules
sitting there on Microsoft's line you
just forgot to get it from there up into
where I flies in the into the vacuum
chamber so what people did is they just
whacked the surface with a high-energy
particle and blasted stuff off the
surface of this was a desperation move
must be said and so had a name though so
fast atom what work is our fam and so
that was the main technique used in
places trying to become the proteomics
Center for decades i lightly a fab like
this you know would be like trying to
measure something delicate like you know
many flowers or something growing on the
desert floor by wagging in with a
meat-eor it is not a good way to subtly
get these delicate objects up into the
atmosphere right it sort of worked but a
very few of the intact species actually
made it off of the flaccid sir all right
Gail scientists figure this out I had
nothing to do with it I'm just the
messenger here okay but it's a but
they're friends of mine and I think it's
nice things how they how they eat this
problem any
by thinking about how how charged
particles move around in liquids as a
lot to do with understanding how water
interacts electricity and that's the
title of our talk today so electricity
doing something with ions charged
particles moving around in water
properties of that or all you need to
know if you say carefully in order to
beat that overcome the problem of
pulling intact molecules out of solutes
all right let's think about you know
some some Lions moving around the water
turns out this has been done for a long
time right after electricity was
discovered 1790 William Nicholson for
example good an interesting experiment
and so I guess it's cooking so those of
you in the front row maybe we can take a
look maybe we can come on up let me take
a look you need to report back on what
we're seeing on our first experiment so
we got here but let me see yeah what is
that it's a what's going on the top
there's so there's the water it's like
lower here than here right and anything
what do we make me look like maybe
bubbles are running up there Boulder
starting off down at the bottom
bubble to the top and push the water
damn this bikes like this place is like
air on this size Ernesto yeah okay so
thank you gentlemen appreciate it and so
what we've just seen of course is the
famous experiment of the electrolysis of
water that's using electricity to take
h2o and turn it back into the elements
from which it came you get two hydrogen
molecules and one oxygen molecule when
you electrolyzed water it has been known
for a long long time now if you take the
gaps that we just generated and you put
them in bloom which we have done and
take the gas it comes to this balloon
for example Aaron what it's going to
tell us a little bit about the
properties of those of those gases that
we just created okay so when I fear some
blue gas the same gas that is being
formed when we're splitting this water
apart and so we notice that on one side
there appeared to be more gas on the
other side well the gas there's more of
it that's the hydrogen that's the we
know water is h2o we're splitting water
on this side and the hydrogen the other
side that's only half as much volume
that's the oxygen so what a happier are
balloons of each one of those gases the
first one is oxygen this doesn't float
in that just here this is full pure
oxygen what I want to do is blow this
blew it up and see what happens so first
off I'm just going to be doing oxygen
all right I bring my little candle up I
want to see how it burns normal balloon
now that's how normal balloons pop not
very exciting however we can make it a
little more exciting when we look at the
hydrogen so hydrogen we can see is
lighter than that is here and it gives
up it we really think of burning we
usually think about something a burns
into into black right it burns into it
turns back into carpet well this is just
hydrogen in here when we burn it
actually turns right back into the water
so let's see what happens when I do that
another one here
all right before I finish the really
neat thing is that we think when our car
burns gasoline we know it makes carbon
dioxide and other pollutants when I burn
this balloon it's actually just making
water I'm forming the water all over
again so here we go once again take a
look at the screen when this happens
well all right thank you very
little electricity little water you know
all right so that's what son as well as
I say a long time ago watching how the
interesting thing happened he do that
that's the experiment that we just saw
so our front row in the audience
verified that we had different levels of
gas that was made when we when we pass a
voltage difference actually and of
course Yale you may have heard of the
news Yale is just starting the FD the
Energy Institute on the west campus and
that has everything to do with learning
how to do that on the grand scale with
taking light from the Sun and turning
that water back into hydrogen and during
that hydrogen in a methanol and finding
a way to make fuels that don't that
don't yield a net co2 production in the
atmosphere and are renewable so that's a
big deal on the Yale campus and there's
a lot of effort that was already here
and now it's been formalized in a new
thing that's going on in our community
ok the next thing we need to understand
in order to in order to get our head
around proteomics is water just by
itself doesn't open job of interacting
with electricity transfecting these
elementary gases but if you take
something and put it in water but we're
going to win proteins in water but let's
the start small start simple and put an
acid a hydrochloric acid we're going to
put that in water and see what it does
what we know that passenger bad for us
right they burn yourself with assets and
so on so we don't want to get too close
to this demonstration so we're going to
use salt instead of hyper for gas to the
guys
1884 this stuff's been around forever
and I'm going back to the archaic
literature here to show that any of
these people could have put proteins in
the gas phase and done brownie on it a
hundred years ago it's trivial when you
see how to do it no one was thinking
about the experiments that we all learn
in high school ok so let's look at what
electricity does when you actually put
something in it that separates itself
into charged particle there and back by
popular demand all right so I've got a
light bulb set up here I'll just prove
to you that I can still make a light
bulb turn on easily by moving this clamp
together so the electricity has to
travel through this clamp for the
electricity to go but then when it's
open no electricity goes doing alright
so we know that when you go to your
favorite a swimming pool the
thunderstorm is coming to kick you out
of the pool because I don't want you to
get electrocuted but if there's a way to
find the pool that had really pure water
I think you'd actually pretty safe so
let's see what happens when I place this
clamp which and there's a connection the
light turns on into pure water huh we
all we all think of water that and
that's electricity but it's actually
doesn't collect conduct electricity well
at all when is pure so I can prove once
in the water I press it together the
connections still there but electricity
wants to flow through water on its own
let's think of another thing we all know
about a sugar right sugar water it's
like almost lemonade let's see if you
maybe would you be safe or not if you
slam it a full of lemonade all right so
I'm going to pour a lot of sugar into
this water mix it around do my best when
I put sugar a water it still doesn't
collect conduct electricity
it's pretty interesting maybe a little
different than what we would expect
light bulbs still work in sugar water
won't conduct all right so now I have
another thing of pure water still not
conducting electricity instead of adding
sugar i'm going to add assault related
to that HCL that he had up on the on the
board so what I'm going to do here is do
my best to put the tiniest bit of table
salt in here see what happens turn off
the lights think it's a little more for
me yeah all right so my phone was off
let's see what happens when I put a tiny
tiny bit a table salt in there so a tiny
tiny bit of salt in there not nothing
yet a tiny tiny bit more so I put it I
put just a dash of that salt and it's
now I add more and more to it
magic right so this salt sounds like
it's different than the sugar it is
saying that we have different kind of
molecules that sugar is a different kind
of molecule and salt salt if you
swimming in the ocean it's certainly not
safe when you're when there's a
lightning storm because that will
conduct electricity but if you're in an
ocean of sugar water thingy all right
all right Erin thank you gauge okay so
we have two down so what we just saw
going on there is what happens when you
put salt into water the sodium fluoride
separates the sodium from the chlorine
and the sodium becomes positively
charged and the chlorine becomes
negatively charged those of those
charged things I was talking to you
about the way back to the beginning and
if I have charged objects and I quit
them and I equip a positive it's like
you saw in our lecture demonstration one
of these is positive and the other is
negative the charge is running to their
relative expected electrode says they're
swimming independently in a liquid
solution that's what you need to know
you click the assault assault into water
it was white they both look white it has
a little too same one man property we
put in water it does not separate and
make start part over ions and in the
other case in sugar and the age of salt
is great and breaking apart and make
honor presented goes to these chart
thing and you use a little pine in fact
that you're good conductor electricity
okay so we have those independent ions
swimming around this tailgators candies
firm up we just did to this if I put
salt into water the positives and
negatives or an ambush
independently if I put an electric if I
put electricity and play ill it'll
attract the opposites and that was the
conductivity we saw with the swimming of
the electrical charges towards their
favorite electrode in eating opposite
directions that was what was conducting
electricity okay so people have known
this since 1888 out and so what was
stopping them from you using using this
knowledge turns out before I die no go
on with that Yael Yael in the in the
1930s was very interested in these
properties of how charges interact with
water and I don't know so this is a
picture of our 1930s era Gail chemistry
department person her be hardened I
don't know that anybody's hurt hurt me
I'm not going to be Feinstein kind of
name appreciate that but our net is the
guy that many of you may have heard out
there and I school you know the types
that the neutral pH of water seven if I
know that fact dh7 neutral water you
can't get ph of the amount of hydrogen
ion that's in the water you can't get
rid of it and that's why you conduct
very well because it's tiny the tiny
amount at neutral water PH right and so
Herbert has got imagine that in 1934
good at using electro chemistry and I
and so we have sold into everyone's life
a little math must fall go on to that
today all right eh done a neutral waters
yelping turns out hearted there's a no
Yale player in this equation this fits
this guy John's eleanii he was the
chairman of the physics department at
yale in nineteenth money now hearted is
well known around New Haven as remember
I talked about my hero when I was high
school noticed Lawrence got an element
named after him of Zelda me fireman he
was the chairman of the physics
department we didn't see any value in
technique set that Lawrence was building
up or at least I'm blaming him for
letting it happen behind types of you
know an excellent guy going out west so
but that's not why we brings eleanii up
to remind ourselves and painful past we
brings eleanii up because he's the guy
that is a very serious experiment yes
you're told why would you even do this
experiment and what he did is he had put
a syringe and have a syringe for you for
you up here that's the needle of the
syringe that funny out yeah that's right
it's got a little bit trip going on
there and so here's what this is the
same thing this is just a syringe that
you know we got from like the health
center and it's getting pushed by a
motor so it's just continuing to drip a
little bit less ugly is but one electron
out rode on one side in the water well
you put two electrode to just conduct we
just saw it but then he was the other
electrode outside the water curious
thing to do if they were both dipped in
hanford running back and forth like
balls of light that be the end of it so
now I told you it's hard to pull those
ions out of there I was abusing my third
row in order to make that point and so
what happens if you think they still
obey the laws of electricity positives
want to go one way they just want to go
the other way I turn on the electric
force and look any negatives and go and
they can they can interact with a
positive electrode negative electrode
will draw the positive stuff until they
all get to just skin to the surface and
then they stop right that's what's going
to happen has appt is too hard pull
those things out of solution we already
went over that grant but that didn't
stop jelanie from resisting and he kept
turning up the voltage we turned up the
voltage a little bit
I mean one day playing what starts to
happen and so will see this ourselves
into the second what starts to happen is
all the positives get pushed together
and in it and they all start to push the
surface of the liquid away turn the
voltage up a little higher the force
becomes stronger you can push them so
hard that they break off a drop you
overcome the surface tension the drops
still there all the items ready you
never asked the ions to like get out of
the water that's bad you're we talked
about that but now I have an object
that's flying through the air that has
halfway to what I want kids got DNA
molecules on the inside water still
surrounding them now my job is just to
get rid of the water and that's the
that's the next thing we have to talk
about but Aaron what you show us what
happens to curious thing that happened
when electricity hits the surface of our
engine award alright so so up on the
screen here we have a needle just like a
like yeah you go to the doctor and
you're going to needle stuck in you this
is the same kind of thing and there's a
drip of water coming from it right now
and you can see it dripping there and
it's it's basically just falling
straight down right because we haven't
we haven't connected the electricity yet
but if I i if I turn on the electricity
we can start small and weak to watch
what happens to the droplet and you can
get the links
alright so it's just dripping will bring
up the electricity
and pretty soon it's not going to be
dropping straight down anymore it's
going to be kind of going out to the
right so those are the charges running
away from from the needles we can keep
going up what voltage or you have their
mind so right now we're at about 3,000
volts should we go a little higher
there's there's 4,000 my clothes okay
we'll go to 5,000 there's 5,000 th make
a little bit higher 6,000 should we do a
little bit there there's seven thousand
volts okay better start taking that
sucker back down look at that happen
alright so want you to look at the sink
fan like that all these these all
started off a little droplet they were
running away because they were
positively charged right and they were
drawn towards the negative electrode the
entire drop is flying across foot across
the gap carrying the water with okay now
the reason is fanned out like that think
about that everybody why wouldn't have
that curious shake let me you can drive
it back up to Cecilia wipes out one more
time but that said not a drop any more
it goes to this fan pattern it's a very
very very funny missed on that happen
alright and so and the reason is
standing out anyway
guess why do that why would days why
would he come great Marge yeah back in
the back oh my goodness what's your day
will you coach no that's a brilliant
answer it is exactly correct so you
round of applause all right so these all
these little droplets are coming out and
they're all I me positively charged and
they want to run away from each other
and it's easy to see that because
looking a runaway girl fanning out to
get as far away as they possibly can
thanks Mike Mike kamrath is our man on
the spot and so that's a curious thing
that a lot of us didn't see coming and
so it has that has very interesting
properties to work that was not many 28
okay proteomics didn't happen until
nineteen ninety-two that it's the same
effect so overall they do it out for you
look summer is that they make what's
called an electrospray electrospray is a
way you do grab things out of solution
and keep enough of the oven native
solution environment around that it
remains happy as it fly through the air
with the greatest of ease and here they
are flying away so it has all people
study these structures that I lost my my
it's okay my froyo here so let's go
spray is what we're talking about and so
there are nice pictures of how these
things can be manipulating so on and
there's a whole engineering that's
associated with the manipulation of that
effect okay so the first person that
tried to put big molecules that would
not survive extraction up into the
assays is this guy Malcolm dole at
Northwestern 1968 you think about this
you know at the 68th man on the moon 69
I mean real thing stuffs have to stop
real DNA meanwhile we're still pulling
away trying to figure out how you models
come out of that solution dole tries it
and he had an apparatus and he wrote you
know in science we write these we fill
up these thick volumes of the scientific
literature is almost nobody reads and so
on it there this one is you know volume
49 in page you know a few thousand or
some journal of chemical physics he
wants to see macro diet that's the name
he used for these large things that
don't want to come out of solution any
idea is to keep breaking the part it's a
fractal kind of idea you keep the charge
starts to evaporate his idea is if you
evaporate the water around all the
targets you think about that you take
five friends who don't like each other
very much and they're all standing as
far as the pop as they wait as they can
from each other and then you say okay
everybody take one step forward you are
now much closer to the people that I
told you you don't want ye are not happy
with it and you get another step forward
and you're touching ooh you're touching
each other horrible and so it will break
apart all by itself the acts of
evaporation forces the charges to go
into a repelling environment and then
they just split out they split split
split until you're finally down to one
happens right actually one charge you
just stick you just like an alligator
clip from radio shack on use the syringe
for the health plan and you get one eye
on that comes out of this thing no
matter how they're you so DNA works it
worked in 1928 it worked in 1968 and
still nobody got it like what was that
what was stopping them and this is the
last little Yale thing I want to I want
to share with you in that in his paper
this is slightly technical but I think
it's valuable to go through it he waved
them he got these things into an into a
vacuum so he had pure trajectories
weighed them perfectly and they were not
the weight of the things he put in new
what he put in by another method you did
all this work got it out weighted
exactly it's not the
same stuff so that's disappointing
Malcolm dole never figures it out right
and in that paper however he said whoa
you know it doesn't everything work just
like I thought but it doesn't work and I
don't know why and in that paper he
references this guy John bed right
jon-fen was on the chemical engineering
faculty at Yale do nothing about or
cared about biological molecules gasps
baby is what he knew about what
conditions he was a guy in World War two
that worked on the chemical engineering
of burning rockets but he got his PhD
get this he got his PhD with Harnett at
Yale the guy who did the neutral th
measurement so he knew about this
electrical stuff quite outside of his
new love which was rocketry so let's
just pause for a moment and get to know
our hero of our story jon-fen so he
arrives a Yale and starts to make this
right working on his doctorate in
chemistry pretty exciting times no we
were assigned to our advisors I recall
her be that furby hearted as he was
known but not address cinque anni fen
you might as well go work with Gus after
a lot paccar laughs kid went on the rat
and won the Nobel Prize dark and
economic you did suffer but this is what
it was like yelled at time obviously I
was something less than inspired by his
introduction to original research the
experiments were a boring pointless
chore with do redeeming features the
results contain no surprises and nothing
of much interest to anyone least of all
me now that's not the kind of alumni
report you like to get from the PhD
candidate in your institution all right
and he was very outspoken about Jack
bunch of the research by heartedness
colleagues was on the properties of
electrolytes that's science apply the
more than i nuked the better so narrow
was this focus that when i left yale
halfway i left heel halfway believe me
the physical chemistry was the slightly
study of slightly contaminated water
okay so worked out okay
you'll see the second though and so in
that white white mountain bowl reference
finished he's had nothing to do with
this story so far turns out it was the
rocket stuff he dole had an idea that
somehow they weren't drying out and that
was the problem couldn't get rid of it
couldn't get rid of the residual solvent
and so a Fed knew about how gas is
rushing through small holes or apertures
that's what a rocket is you got fuel
burning through a tiny aperture that
then propels the rocket and every time
you ever seen a piccy look up in the sky
there's a jet airplane behind that jet
airplane what you see white what's white
ice right it's crystals of ice that are
forming that brought the moisture in the
air or the fuel that's burnt by the
engine and so the spontaneous formation
of a droplet in humid air is what he
would put what Malcolm Dole was
accidentally finding out and fed knew
that if you have very very cold gas ions
love to attract the surrounding water
vapor into droplets a spontaneous need
more and rough and that's when our
little demonstrations about so there's a
little rocket engine that FEM might have
worked on and so in that in the plume of
that rocket exhaust you get you get a
stream a little chocolates that are
coming out now that's why we have our
lecture demonstration which is our last
thing good to think about it is it is
part of it is yeah what we're looking at
here is called a cloud chamber so old
cloud chamber is that these were very
common in the 60s when I went to the
lawrence hall science i saw a cloud I
don't you know hyatt nuclear physics is
no longer in vogue so I don't suppose
they pay high schoolers see clouds I'm
bringing one two you could they're fun
and so what are we looking at here the
drive you come up and look at it after
the lecture what I'm doing is making a
cloud in the box is kind of fun
and so what we've done is we've taken a
cold bottom that's dry ice we're all
familiar with dry ice co2 and so that's
colder than that much colder than dense
than water ice and then I have alcohol
like the kind of alcohol you can drink
that's in that's it that's forming a
vapor because the top plate is hot but
then as it goes down towards the cold
place it gas gets colder and colder and
as it starts to get cold enough it
reaches the dew point and then it starts
to rain and you're seeing the rain a
little droplet you're sitting is a very
fine mr. Rana palcohol that's coming
down and there it is boy and so if we
study this cloud formation like doing if
we look at it for a couple of seconds
they might be able to find one and so I
won't wait there was a little one track
that went there you can see a little
printers went up there if you've been
watching that's an imperfection in the
glass if you've been watching this thing
you will note that occasionally there
are brilliant streaks there was a streak
so there okay you guys believe it
there's like stretchy stuff happening
all right very rare occasional streaks
any idea like then I gave you a group in
the beginning of the lecture right so
what we're getting to know you I think
many of you heard about bad be going to
Mars when you have like a sun spots if
you heard that stuff so you get into
hannah pilots have trouble when they're
up by the atmosphere because they get
exposed to radiation that we're not
shielded from by our atmosphere this is
the radiation that we're living with
every day their cosmic rays very very
very high-energy small particles that
can't the thing you have to get about
this because the particles came through
the roof of the building came through
the ceiling went through the box and
then are you are you can visualize them
why because the particle is moving so
quickly through this vapor that's trying
to make a cloud that what it does is it
not
an electron off of an alcohol molecule
and that makes it a electrically charged
things but this particle coming from the
cosmos is so high-energy it didn't even
notice it's clueless it goes through and
knocked off an electron from you and you
and you and you and along that line each
one of you then break gathers up a
solvent drop because their aunt because
the vapor that wants to make a cloud
loves the iron as the place to see that
cloud so if the trajectory of a cloud
seeding that you're seeing from cosmic
ray radiation that is causing a
macroscopic droplet to form by
introducing an eye on along its
trajectory that the cloud chamber and
we've just seen we've seen lots and lots
of alcohol molecules have clung on to a
little Bionic Center and started the
start of that process of pouty so fed
realize this in 1969 and it took him ten
years to dry out the drug he just he's
healed he reasoned that the reason no
one's getting the right mass as you
simply have to put in a way to drive off
the water vapor and it couldn't be
simpler out in the end after ten years
what works well you take you take a hair
dryer and you heat up a tube of light
copper that you might use in your house
for a refrigerator or something like
that and you just pass these these
droplets through it and as they get
heated up when they go through it it
evaporates them all down where they have
their lone single biological I
involvements left so then put a drying
to on a 1928 experiment that's it and
when he did it cytochrome C comes up
just remember i show you nitrogen and
oxygen measured with great precision
removing Wade those out now you can
weigh out an object that's 20,000 times
bigger than that with the same precision
no problem no I ends left on it you get
exact competition composition of these
gigantic speech that's what they do down
there is they get your stuff out of your
body they have put into another
pro spray and then these sequins wow
you're put together using this simple
technology does it have an impact oh
let's think about that David Davis
California 1995 it's a los angeles
superior court it's the simpson matter
okay so let's talk about you know
whether what was electrospray done for
us what technique to the FBI use if you
many of you are as old as i am will
remember it all came down to the DNA
evidence and it was always like how do
they hit the DNA evidence the FBI used a
method where the liquid goes through a
very tiny tiny but moderately long piece
of glass capillary that's been drying
thick it has a tiny it is a glass tube
with a tiny tiny opening any tiny run
that is heated and has applied to it a
very high very high voltage any moderate
amount percentage a high electricity I
have no idea what that means that's a
court record of this thing that's why
it's called electrospray and so that's
what you know many of you are seeing
NCIS anybody watch NCIS out there what's
a be doing with his mass spectrometer
and his find out of the bosom of the
evildoer dog she's doing this was an
electrospray that came to us from
jonathan the one thing i want to leave
with you is the main thing about electro
spray is that it does the magic job of
taking anything you have in liquid and
and stripping it out of the liquid
non-destructively jon-fen was rewarded
with a Nobel Prize for his efforts in
2002 and it's and is credited with being
the father of proteomics even though he
himself didn't care a whit about project
and so the epilogue here is a casual
reference to a paper that was Malcolm
dole to an unrelated in an unrelated
field relayed by a colleague in another
Department was a key to the whole thing
happening in 68 nobody trying to solve
the problem of pulling the molecules out
had any had any idea that this was going
to be
way to do it so directing the effort to
the answer you wanted didn't allow that
there could be accidents that would be
the key to the whole thing working and
here's what I love about this thing is
once you know it everyone can do it you
can't hard to make money on it it's
simple and cheap and it works perfectly
well thanks to listening and I want to
bring up by my helpers who put together
our demonstrations and we'll give them a
round of applause Rachel well twisting
Russ Britt Aaron Beck my camera and
Helen Girardi